hey Google you say is the most important  lesson you've learned in your life  most important lesson  treating others like you want to be  treated you know and you've got to treat  other people  like you would want them to treat you  so if you go out robbing people and you  know slapping them around in this net um  and apparently you don't want such a  good life handed to you but if you want  peace and love and happiness and fun and  stuff like that then you put that out  and that's what you get  I believe in that and my most important  lesson in life that I've learned  is that you gotta take care of you gotta  show people kindness and love  and uh you'll get it back but if you  don't if you've got heavy price debate  prison  uh fights murder